[Music]
do Moran thank you um so much for
joining me it is November 2nd 2023 27
days after the terrible events of
October 7th when um everything you know
changed um where um you know lots of
things are you know are coming out as as
you know in in part of our ecosystem the
startup Nation um and I can't think of a
better figure um to to speak to about
what we're observing what we're
observing from the ecosystem aspect on
on a personal aspect from from the
technology to society to the um to the
um community at large so thank you very
much for for joining me um and I I
really appreciate it before we get into
the war and what's happening give me a
brief background about yourself and and
your day-to-day work with Grove and
obviously your name speaks before you
but I'd love to hear it in your own
words hey great talking to you Michael
uh so I'm I'm a entrepreneur I'm a
founder of companies inventor USB
flashl it
is uh other other nice company this by
company I've ssts acquired by sis $1.6
billion that need the a uh the smallest
fing the world this one actually take a
look at the size of the USB flash dve
and actually one was this this is even
smaller yeah uh and this is mod that was
patterns were acquired by Google I was
German of th and kodo the made it turn
around and in the last many years last
eight years I am the managing part of
grow Ventures we are very unique fund
lip Tech uh all the hardcore difficult
stuff like semiconductors Cloud
infrastructure energy uh Quantum space
uh heare and uh we are strive to
actually uh help Israeli startups to
become
successful and we are doing very well
with that and you uh and and you you
still start off all by saying you're an
entrepreneur that's H eight even eight
years now full-time venture capitalist
that's it that's who you are I still
still see myself as entrepreneur because
entrepreneurship is something that exist
in your DNA means uh you know people ask
can I people from other countries come
to Israel and ask how can we become the
Sal of nation how can we say sayy you
can't really copy you can improve
yourself it's like run Mar on Runners
you can't it's clearly the the winners
usually are coming from uh from Africa
because it's part of their you know DNA
they they learn how to run and over
doens or or hundreds of thousands of
generations they improved their
capabilities uh to become very good
marathon runners now from time to time
there are Mar Runners that are from
other countries because it's not only
what's in your DNA what do you do with
it uh I think that entrepreneurship is
part of the is DNA that's what lead to
the situation that we have so great many
many great startups so many winners of
Nobel Prize and uh and therefore
entrepreneurship yeah I'm I a venture
capital fund manager here but I'm still
entrepreneur I still when I go to invest
I always work with the company I'm not
just the sending money yeah right a
check um the the the the check is a it's
maybe the first stage of beginning
longterm relations between us the fund
and the company the entrepreneurs of
fighting side by side in order to make
it a great success story so bringing me
and my partners all our experience and
many many years of uh activities and
relations and connections and
understanding using the mostly the scars
that we have in our back many many
scares if I take the shirt you say my
old back is full of scarves but that's
that's what we are what I'm doing I I
can I can just share from a from a young
entrepreneurs perspective the
inspiration that you provide a a whole
generation of young entrepreneurs and so
on behalf of myself and all my friends
in my generation I I think you for that
um you know these inventions you've done
are not only incredible Technologies and
and um intellectually um intellectually
inspiring I think they're you've also
been a a Pioneer in in pivoting the way
you know know for the Israeli ecosystem
right I mean this is you know your
stories you you've done this and and you
know today when I create a company in
Tel Aviv or in Califoria is in Israeli
I'm sitting on a platform uh that is
very supportive huge community that
you're part of the supportive Community
yet many of course it's of course of
course but but I but I have to recognize
that your time as as as you know
pioneering a lot of the um a lot of
these inv
it was a different time and a different
spirit so so first of so thank you but
but let's let's talk about an additional
scar that's added on to what you
mentioned which is obviously what
started in October 7th tell me a little
bit about where you were in October 7th
and then I would love to hear a little
bit about your immediate springing into
action because you've immediately
published a a beautiful piece with your
opinion on it your your fun has been
actively involved so walk me through
that that day that that morning where
you were and then sort of the reaction
to it well this was Saturday 6:30 in the
morning I seen it every isra almost
every Israel will ask we give you the
answer that hey I was in bed sleeping
great life actually last day of the
the hope day everything was peaceful the
weather was great the sky was blue seems
like hey life are good uh and everything
was changed actually in a day uh
everything was changed because uh within
few hours you understood that this is a
catastrophe and the numbers just got
added and growing an hour after an hour
and then you get calls from people that
you know and uh and this is in trouble
and this lady doesn't know where where
is and uh you know and hey our life was
changed uh our life was
changed that every every every I don't
every you know somebody if he didn't
experience it himself more the the
people who are very close to him at the
second year at least uh he knows
somebody that you know was there his
body was there his her parents died and
and and the stories are
amazing amazing terrible stories because
this is not people who died while
bombarding or whatever which is bad by
itself these are people who were killed
by by uh creatures creatures that I I I
even Cann can find as terrorist because
terrorist are having a gun they shoot
they bomb they take their plan and go
enter into the the the the the three
towers uh and and but people who
actually uh burn elderly people at their
bed people who shoot children in front
of the eyes of the parents all parents
in front of the eyes of the children uh
people terrorists or elements that they
just cut the the
the baby out of his
mother's you know these these are things
that we saw only at this very very
terrible pictures of the ice
and this is the kind of the enemies we
are standing in front so this was a
shock it was a shock to all of us a
selective shock uh a collective shock
and this will be a scarf at the at this
country's life I think for forever and
ever um and then by the way I think
which made me so this you you feel sad
because I I spoke with many of these
guys I went to several Shiva you know
Shiva when people die and you go to
seven days you go and sited there with
them you go you go many people are
coming and they they always speak about
you know the relatives I went to many
shivas I know many people unfortunately
the the relatives died I know many
people so should the whole people you
know the people you you encounter with
that and they came these pictures from
from abroad where you see uh people
demonstrating free Gaza what free Gaza I
I seen it yes I am in Gaza I don't want
to be in Gaza I have no interest in Gaza
I would love I would love that Gaza
people ref free themselves from the
Hamas so hey the first response I'm
joking now hey I'm with them but then
they say free Gaza Gaza or or the
Palestinian from the sea from The River
To The Sea hey if it's from The River To
The Sea where I supposed to live this
these people are from Americans Germans
Italians China turkey turkey yeah uh
what What's in their mind what what
exactly are they thinking about are they
really striking for peace this lady from
Sweden I think s which you know has all
the signs of of save the economy and all
the rest you know fre Gaza come what
does she understand about Gaza about is
she really can she really fight place in
their heart for such enemies such not en
animals such terrorist that did this
kind of thing she's comparing it uh to
to what uh so you know it's it's it's
feeling in a way they said this is this
the world this is where we live in a
place which has so much evil actually
and then there is a concern and concern
about what's going on because maybe we
are of that maybe we are just at the
beginning of a
big a big situation a big war actually
and we see only the first size and uh
and if there'll be a big war clearly uh
the numbers of people died over
1300 uh will be just the beginning of a
larger number and clearly this may get
to the whole world and I think that it's
a and it's a you know obviously
geopolitically we're one of the
most terrifying and complex situations
we we've been at um ever and this is why
there's so much Global discussion here
and and the spotlight on Israel one of
the things that I was inspired by and
you are a part of that is the action of
the way that the startup nation has come
together Beyond just beyond just the the
you know the reserves and the that all
stuff but but really we saw the
ecosystem that day United coming
together which to me you know reminded
me of the stories of my grandmother and
my grandfather from the ha and from
those early days what did you experience
happening in our ecosystem starting that
day well clearly the picture is is much
more broader than what in the sky
because there are many there are the bad
things there are the strange things
there are the good things as well first
the amazing support of Biden uh which
was so
clear so amazing so so clear in the
message in the fact that he came to
Israel at this time
sh you know I think that his response
was very very effective and very very
good uh not just for Israel but
generally for keeping the situation
controlled um support of many leaders in
Europe actually I seen that every leader
in Europe that bed to understand the
situation Who are the he thought who is
the right and wrong because there's no
right and wrong here who is the evil
guys and who are the guys who actually
looking for peaceful life what the guys
who actually driven by bying a bying a
religious which says Jihad kill
everybody who is not Muslim to the guys
who are looking at progress at
technology at how to make this world
better this is the real battle so you
get to see all the Europeans almost all
all the European lead
coming to Israel supporting Israel in an
amazing amazing way and of course the
most the nicest thing and I had no doubt
that this is us Israelis is the
big solidity big big friendship a big
support from one to the other everybody
yeah uh without thinking about money
time uh you know anything uh that that
was this is an amazing stuff which I
believe is is very very unique to
Israel H and uh and despite my concern
about a global war I do believe that
global war will not happen my again I'm
I'm not trying to be you know to see the
future or talk about to be a prophet but
I see that I do hope and believe that
all
this very very bad issue will keep
detained in a way and we see the the
kidna guys coming back to Israel by I
don't care for what take all the
prisoners the Prisoners the Palestinian
Prisoners the terrorists out of here
that's great uh and and that Gaza will
get out of the control of Hamas they are
the real kid by the way the the citizens
of Gaza the guys who are suffering from
the fact that the Hamas takes all the
money use this money not for building
hospitals education economy stuff which
are good for the people but being
building weapon Building C caves below
the ground which by the way they don't
allow the the citizens the Palestinians
go into these C caves they keep it for
themselves that's amazing the level of
coolness not just them against us them
against the own people I think that we
find a way to keep the Hamas out of
control and actually slash and get other
organization get probably International
to get into Gaza to
create a right entity that would have
their life their land their uh abilities
to really make something better than
live well uh live live good life
peaceful life I do hope that this will
happen I have no doubt no doubt that the
Hightech in Israel will
recover and all this uh you know I spoke
about Israelis as entrepreneurs as part
of the this part of the DNA not by the
way not just Israelis but Jews surely
worldwide many generation where the
non-entrepreneurs
died finally you keep a small group 14
million people all over the world or 16
actually uh and uh you know it's a small
group it's a where we small small tiny
nation and U and all of these guys are
the guys who generation after generation
just end up and survive part of
Entrepreneurship is the ability to of
come rises part of it is the
ability
to to be strong and be strong especially
at the tough times and uh I I do believe
that this war it's a war this this war
would help us to get out of the
situation we've been before with a
government that as you know M I was not
happy with to go and to be in a position
that we rebuil a country with a better
infrastructure with a better methods
with a better management because for
many many years what happened in this
country is that the smart guys not with
others the smart guys went to Hightech
went to Industry went to finance and the
guys and the guys who actually went to
politics were not the right guys to go
there we created a situation where there
were bad people to choose from and there
were bad parties to to do with with
agendas which are very bad and all of
this would would have to be changed and
I S I do believe it will do it when you
look at the ecosystem today and you're
you're you know you're um guiding many
companies and entrepreneurs you're also
a figure that's observant as to what's
happening in the sentiment amongst
entrepreneurs and Company leader within
Israel what are you observing on on a
leadership perspective what are you
observing of the the leadership within
the startup Nation over the last three
and a half three and a half weeks almost
a month what what has been some of the
characteristics that you've learned
about you know our our existing
leadership here not government the the
start up
scene uh well I have to go we talk about
leadership there is a leadership which
is you know the guys who are working
every day in h in supporting
helping the Army the the people around
Gaza the people who the relatives were
were kidnapped are the people from the
north that had to leave their houses we
have a threat from the north as well
over 150 people currently left their
houses they are actually uh how do you
call it
PL refugees yeah how do you say
yeah refugees they are refugees in
Israel yeah byway it's my home we have a
family from marot I have a a house in in
a place called yakona which is for all I
built for my my daughter and this the S
family is coming from from another part
of the everybody gives it does a lot of
things I do believe that this the effort
that you think is led by amazing people
and none of them were politician you see
the all the politicians are W they know
they they they are not hiding but you
don't see them you don't see them their
activities they I tell you why they are
incapable y so
um uh this is a a situation where I do
believe that this change of leadership
political leadership because you
definitely know a country is led by
political leaders would cause a change
if good people we go into politics will
have to actually generate uh a new sort
of leaders which should be humble uh the
strengths won't be how great they talk
English but how uh how great uh they
think about their people uh they they we
know how to manage you know our prime
minister fortunately except politics he
never managed anything there was Ry
sales at the furniture companies B yeah
the Big B was a VP sales of them
Furniture companies or the rest of his
life political Affairs yeah uh we see
people coming with uh the real will of
of fighting for this country and to
fight for peace and I tell you something
which I think is very crucial when I was
young at you know all
generations we we were taught that we
have
to to search to strive for this and this
was part of our living
understanding uh the story will say we
are small country and as strong as we'll
be we have to be strong because we have
many enemies but we have to strive for
peace I see it over the years this
message that hey we have to strive for
peace somehow this me everybody of
course anyway strive for peace it wasn't
the flag and it has to become a flag we
have to strive for peace and peace with
our neighbors where is Palestinians
where is Egyptians where is Jordan where
is Syria where is Lebanon because that's
the place we choose to live in in Israel
we are surrounded by these neighbors
good and bad and everybody has you know
strengths and and and weaknesses and I
do believe that this eventually will
come I I love the optimism and I love
how you're constantly thinking about the
next day and where how we emerge out of
this crisis into a new generation and
and the evolution of our people and in
this country and and and I share your
optimism and I and you're making me even
more optimistic what is your what is
your message to entrepreneurs these days
this is going to be a long long battle
what what is your message to
entrepreneurs CEOs company Founders and
leaders over over these next
months so first of all we we we are
talking constantly with all the CEOs of
all we have set C is our Port CA is our
portfolio we stick with all the SE daily
uh sometimes depend with who quickly the
worst case they they are all working
they all working it's not the same weate
but we did recommend to them go back go
back to work uh go back to collect the
people uh uh make them come make them
get out of the watching TV day all day
long and then you know social networks
said they do it so first of all we have
to live with the situation we have to
know to overcome the the the you know
the the
scenario H the idea guys we are now in
the process of recovering it takes time
yeah they don't over push but you have
to go through the process you went into
an accident now you have to learn how to
walk and then run again and then drive
again uh so we have to begin this
process and they are doing that my
recommendation to the to
ENT uh move on with uh your ideas your
companies your startups H go put the
time put the effort put the strengths
into this other than watching
today
uh and be strong luckily luckily this
ugly attack this terrible attack didn't
destroy Hightech didn't destroy
Innovation didn't destroy ENT
preneurship we do have great
entrepreneurs we do have as well great
community of supporters investors from
worldwide all all over the world let
understand that this is what we are
doing this in this country and I do
believe that yeah maybe it would take
some time for them to come back and
invest but the smart guys would come
faster and the smart guys will take
advantage actually of investing in a
good numbers and actually maybe be time
as well to be more humble in the
valuations and take a bre and U don't
jump don't over Jun with ideas like get
get the right times of do doing stuff
and that's okay that's fine yeah and I
think uh you know more than what I've
what I've been looking at some of these
are companies in your in your own
portfolio that are really taking a look
at this crisis and think okay how can we
C catalyze this catalyze our Innovation
catalyze our technology and deploy it in
ways that we didn't necessarily think of
in in this context and I've seen it with
with our own work and with the work of
some of your companies it's it's really
been amazing to see how you know how we
we you know as a start should we come
together and innovate during this time
and do I really want to thank you first
and foremost for the inspiration on a
personal level but on a on a on a
national level and and on a on a global
level as well um you you bring a a very
fresh and energizing perspective very
calming and soothing I I leave this
conversation more calm soothed
optimistic and energized than than than
going into with so so I thank you for
that and uh and thank you for
everything thank
[Laughter]
youe